This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是指旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养坚韧的精神、健康的体魄和建立心理韧性。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。搜索单词“TWO”加“percent”，即可在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我而言都是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义非凡。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人而言，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了法律后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. I don't know what it is at the moment,
对我们的心理而言。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目。我不知道目前是怎么回事，
but there is something in the water because I have been receiving so many DMs, so many requests to do this episode. And today I'm going to do it. Let's jump into it. We're going to talk about the long distance dilemma and that kind of age old question or in some ways a new age question of do I do long distance or do we end it here is the distance too much of a hurdle in my relationship?
但感觉有些不对劲，因为我收到了太多的私信，有太多的听众要求做这一期节目。而今天我打算满足大家。让我们切入正题。我们要聊聊异地恋的困境，这是一个老生常谈的问题，或者在某种程度上是一个新时代的问题：我要不要谈异地恋？还是我们就在这里结束？这段距离是不是我感情中无法逾越的鸿沟？
I think this is such a conundrum for those of us dating in our 20s. During this decade I think our romantic relationships suddenly take on a whole new level of seriousness as we begin to consider the longevity and the nature of this relationship. This could be our life partner. This could be our forever person. And that level of seriousness is not one that we typically had in our teenage years or in the relationships we had in our early 20s. We become a lot more future-orientated in every aspect of our lives. And that includes when it comes to our romantic partners. But at the same time, our 20s also pose this very unique time, I would say, that present so many opportunities to travel, to work abroad or in different states, opportunities that are once in a lifetime that we can't say no to.
我认为对于我们这些二十多岁正在谈恋爱的人来说，这真是一个巨大的难题。在这个十年里，随着我们开始考虑这段关系的持久性和本质，我们的恋爱关系突然上升到了一个全新的严肃水平。这可能会是我们的终身伴侣。这可能是那个能陪我们走到最后的人。这种严肃程度通常是我们十几岁时，或者在二十岁刚出头时的恋爱中没有的。我们在生活的方方面面都变得更具前瞻性。这自然也包括我们的恋爱对象。但与此同时，二十岁也是一个非常独特的时期，我想说，它提供了很多旅行、去国外或外州工作的机会，这些都是千载难逢、无法拒绝的机会。
But sometimes the choices we decide to make aren't going to align with what our partner decides to do. And we have to make a decision. do we try and take this long distance? So how do we make that decision? What are some of the major considerations? What are some of the things you should be looking out for around whether this is going to work? And maybe you've given it a shot, you've done long distance,
但有时我们做出的选择并不符合伴侣的预期。于是我们不得不做一个决定：我们要不要尝试一下异地恋？那么我们该如何做出这个决定？有哪些主要的考量因素？哪些迹象能看出这段感情是否能行得通？也许你已经尝试过了，你们经历过异地，
and it's just not working out. How do we know when it's time to throw in the towel? And I guess leave that relationship behind. I think distance can be hard in any relationship. It really disturbs our closeness. It's harder to make shared memories. It can also be really, really expensive when we account for travel. And I think it's hard when you have to say goodbye as well.
但就是行不通。我们怎么知道什么时候该放弃，或者说结束这段感情？我认为距离在任何恋爱中都是艰难的。它确实会破坏我们的亲密度。创造共同回忆变得更难。考虑到差旅费用，它也可能变得非常非常昂贵。而且我认为每次不得不说再见时也非常非常难。
You know, there's no cutting corners here. It's going to be difficult. And it will test whether this person is the right one for you for all of the correct reasons. It tests your boundaries. It tests the nature of your innate connection, I guess. But there is also a way through it. And I want to talk about that today as well. We're going to discuss all things long distance, starting at what the psychological pillars of a healthy, romantic connection look like,
你知道，这里没有什么捷径可走。这注定是艰难的。它将出于所有正确的理由来考验这个人是否真的是你的真命天子/天女。它考验你的底线。我想，它也考验了你们之间天然连接的本质。但这也是有解决办法的。我今天也想聊聊这个。我们将讨论关于异地恋的一切，首先来看看健康恋爱关系的心理学支柱是什么，
how those are tested by distance, why it is that distance places a strain on our partnership, on our relationship. Also some of the major questions and considerations that you need to contemplate before diving into this arrangement, the signs that it may not be working. And some of the tips to remain connected backed by some fun psychological theories around connection, similarity and emotional intimacy. So for all of my lovely listeners out there who have messaged me, with questions and needing advice on their long distance relationship.
这些支柱是如何受到距离考验的，为什么距离会给我们的伴侣关系和恋爱关系带来压力。还有在你一头扎进这种模式之前，你需要深思熟虑的一些主要问题和考量，以及它可能行不通的迹象。以及一些基于关于连接、相似性和情感亲密度的趣味心理学理论的保持连接的小建议。所以，对于所有给我发私信、询问关于异地恋问题并寻求建议的可爱听友们，
This one is for you. We're going to get into all the nitty gritty and hopefully provide some more clarity around what the future holds and answer some of those questions. I'm so excited to get into it to share a bit of my own experience. And of course, all of the psychology that explains why distance can be so hard. So without further ado, I say we jump right into the long distance dilemma.
这期节目就是为你准备的。我们将深入探讨所有细节，希望能为未来提供更多清晰的指引，并解答其中的一些疑问。我非常兴奋能参与其中，分享我的一些经历。当然，还有所有解释为什么距离如此艰难的心理学原理。所以废话不多说，让我们直接切入异地恋的困境。
Alrighty, let's picture this for a second. You and your partner have been together for three years. You met at 21 when you were at uni. You were super in love. You're still super in love. You may even live together. And you're really going steady. You know, the future seems really bright.
好啦，让我们想象一下这个画面。你和你的伴侣已经在一起三年了。你们在21岁上大学时认识的。你们当时爱得死去活来。现在依然爱得死去活来。甚至可能已经同居了。你们的感情非常稳固。你知道，未来看起来真的很光明。
You can't live without them. And then all of a sudden you get an amazing. opportunity to move into state. It's an incredible offer, more money, your dream job in your dream city, and you're going to take it, but your partner wants to stay where they are. They are equally happy with the opportunities they have at the moment. And in this situation, you kind of face a crossroads. You really only have two options here. Do you start a long distance relationship or do you go your separate ways. And I guess there's also that third alternative, which is to say no to that opportunity and to stay in the same place. That third alternative is not one. I think we're going to talk about
你们不能没有对方。然后突然之间，你得到了一个绝佳的外州发展机会。这是一个令人难以置信的offer，更多的钱，在你梦想城市的梦想工作，你打算接受它，但你的伴侣想留在原地。他们对目前拥有的机会同样感到满意。在这种情况下，你有点面临十字路口。在这里你其实只有两个选择。你是开始一段异地恋，还是各奔东西？我想其实还有第三种选择，那就是拒绝那个机会，留在原地。我觉得第三种选择并不是我们今天要
a lot today. I would not recommend it, especially when we are so young for so many reasons. You know, our 20s are such a time of liberation and freedom. You never know if you'll get this opportunity again or this level of freedom. And I think one day we're inevitably going to be restricted by things like mortgages and children and aging and family. So now is really the time I think where you're allowed to feel selfish. You're allowed to say yes. And even if that's going to change your dynamic, if the person you are with is right for you, they are going to celebrate your success and your decision, they're not going to hold you back. I think secondly, if you say no for the sake of staying together, this can potentially foster resentment if it alters kind of the balance of
重点讨论的。我不会推荐它，特别是在我们这么年轻的时候，原因有很多。你知道，二十多岁是一个崇尚解放和自由的时期。你永远不知道自己是否还能再次获得这样的机会或这种程度的自由。而且我认为有一天我们不可避免地会受到房贷、孩子、衰老和家庭等事情的束缚。所以现在真的是我认为你可以感到自私的时候。你被允许说“好”。即使这会改变你们的动态，但如果和你在一起的人是对的人，他们会为你的成功和决定庆祝，而不是拖你的后腿。其次，如果你为了保持在一起而选择拒绝，如果这改变了你们之间的权力
power and compromises between you both. You know, when one partner consistently has to say no to things, especially when they benefit their personal or professional growth, it can create a real imbalance and I think a big degree of resentment. You know, over time, you begin to feel undervalued and there's also this idea of a sense of missed potential. You know, there was a wonderful study done in 2017 and it examined past and future regret around missed opportunities and kind of that implicit trade-off that occurs and they found that lost opportunities can create regret and resentment and it makes it difficult to achieve psychological closure because you can't change the past you're always kind of going to be haunted by this what if so i think when you're faced with this
平衡和妥协，这可能会潜在地滋生怨恨。你知道，当一方不得不持续对某些事情说不，尤其是当这些事情有利于他们的个人或职业发展时，就会产生真正的不平衡，我认为还会产生很大程度的怨恨。你知道，随着时间的推移，你开始觉得自己被低估了，而且还会有一种错失潜力的感觉。你知道，2017年曾有过一项出色的研究，它考察了围绕错失机会的过去和未来的遗憾，以及其中发生的隐含权衡。他们发现，失去的机会会产生遗憾和怨恨，这使得实现心理上的释怀变得困难，因为你无法改变过去，你总是会被这种“如果当初”的想法所困扰。所以我觉得当你面临这个
dilemma of do i say yes or do i say no for the sake of my relationship my opinion is you should always say yes what's now in question is whether the relationship you're currently in is going to grow with you into this new situation and this new season of life, or maybe you would both be better off kind of calling it quits, saying goodbye. Of course, that is a very nuanced personal decision, and I think distance comes from a lot of factors. You can feel distanced even when you are close together, but there are so many things that also make proximity a massive issue. You know, it's not just that you've gotten this amazing opportunity to say yes or no to, it may also be that you just lived in different countries when you met
“我是该答应，还是为了感情而拒绝”的困境时，我的观点是：你永远应该答应。现在的问题在于，你目前的这段感情能否与你一同成长，适应这个新环境和新的人生阶段，或者你们两个可能索性好聚好散，各自安顿下来更好。当然，这是一个非常微妙的个人决定，而且我认为距离是由许多因素导致的。即使你们靠得很近，你也会感到疏离，但同样有许多事情让物理距离成为一个巨大的问题。你知道，不仅仅是你要对这个绝佳的机会做出或接受的选择，还可能是你们相遇时就住在不同的国家，
or your family needs you, though, all these pressures. But I think regardless of the reason why you are facing this dilemma, we're not going to sugarcoat it here, long distance is super hard. And there are actually a number of psychological reasons why this is the case and which could potentially explain why so few relationships actually survive this experience in this period. You know, there's been so many findings that couples in long-distance relationships, they were more likely to separate compared to those living a short distance away for a number
或者你的家庭需要你，所有这些压力。但无论你面临这个困境的原因是什么，我们在这里都不用美化它，异地恋超级难。这背后其实有很多心理学原因，这也可以潜在地解释为什么在这个时期，极少有恋情能够挺过这段经历。你知道，有太多的研究结果表明，与居住距离较近的情侣相比，异地恋情侣更有可能分开，原因有
of reasons. And I also want to state that isn't always going to be the case. Obviously, every situation is unique, but they are associated. with more individual and relational stress compared to being in a proximal relationship, proximal meaning a short distance or local. I think that's because at the end of the day, relationships are built on psychological and physical factors like proximity, closeness and reciprocity. And when one of these is weakened, we can really struggle to maintain that, romantic connection and sense of trust. I think as humans, we do have an inherent need for
很多。我也想说明，这并不总是绝对的。显然，每种情况都是独一无二的，但相比于近距离恋爱（即短距离或本地恋爱），异地恋会带来更多个体和关系上的压力。我认为这是因为归根结底，恋爱关系建立在心理和物理因素之上，比如物理距离的接近、亲密感和互惠性。而当其中任何一个减弱时，我们就会很难维持那种浪漫的连接感和信任感。我认为作为人类，我们确实对
physical closeness and when that connection is absent or limited, it contributes to feelings of loneliness, to feelings of longing and frustration, which are then projected onto your partner, projection being a psychological coping mechanism whereby we attribute our own feelings to another person rather than acknowledging just the holistic difficulty of the situation that we are in. You know, we don't see it as the distance. We see it as our partner isn't putting in enough effort. We see it as our partner is letting us down, that our partner is not willing to sacrifice for our relationship when that isn't the case.
物理上的亲密有着内在的需求，而当这种连接缺失或受限时，就会导致孤独感、渴望和沮丧情绪，这些情绪随后会被投射到你的伴侣身上。投射是一种心理防御机制，我们将自己的感受归咎于另一个人，而不是去承认我们所处局面的整体艰难性。你知道，我们不认为问题出在距离上，而是认为伴侣没有付出足够的努力。我们觉得伴侣让我们失望了，觉得伴侣不愿意为我们的感情做出牺牲——而事实并非如此。
I think this lack of physical closeness and the strain that places on a relationship can be trace back to the effect and the influence of dopamine. Of course, dopamine is the neurotransmitter that is responsible for pleasure and reward, in addition to things like oxytocin, which is the chemical that allows us to feel love and to feel trust. These neurochemicals are released at much higher rates when we are physically closer to someone, when we can hug and kiss them and be in their presence and they make us feel amazing. And as time goes on, if you've spent a lot of time around this person, you've obviously fallen in love. And we come to depend on these chemicals and the way that they fuel a sense of closeness and intimacy. So when we become physically
我认为这种物理亲密感的缺乏及其给感情带来的压力，可以追溯到多巴胺的作用和影响。当然，多巴胺是负责快乐和奖赏的神经递质，此外还有催产素等化学物质，催产素能让我们感受到爱和信任。当我们与某人在物理距离上更亲近，当我们能够拥抱、亲吻他们并在他们身边时，这些神经化学物质会以更高的速率释放，它们让我们感觉好极了。随着时间的推移，如果你和这个人相处了很长时间，你显然已经坠入爱河。我们开始依赖这些化学物质以及它们所助长的那种亲密感。因此，当我们物理上
distanced, we can go into somewhat of a withdrawal. When these chemicals and neurotransmitters are released at a lower rate. This creates stress, it creates longing and even physical pain, which is a feeling, I think any one of us who've ever been separated from someone we deeply love can understand. On another kind of level as well, this distance can also create opportunities for jealousy, for doubt, and insecurity, because we are no longer able to physically check in regularly and observe each other's daily activities and progress. There's also this element of not being able to talk openly as well
疏远时，我们可能会进入某种戒断状态。这时，这些化学物质和神经递质的释放速率会降低。这会产生压力、渴望甚至生理上的疼痛，我想任何与深爱的人分开过的人都能体会到这种感觉。从另一个层面来看，这种距离也为嫉妒、怀疑和不安全感创造了机会，因为我们不再能够经常进行物理上的打卡探视，并观察彼此的日常活动和进展。这里还有一个因素，那就是无法进行公开的对话，
and respond to cues other than just someone's words. You know, a lot of our communication as humans is not just done through what we verbally express. It's done through small gestures and posture and tone and body language. But when you have to have those hard conversations with your partner through the phone or FaceTime, a lot of that is missed and we can misinterpret what someone is trying to say or feel a lack of trust and a lack of closeness, like we can't really believe them. And of course there is this element of a lack of shared
除了对方的话语之外，无法对其他线索做出反应。你知道，人类的大多数交流不仅仅通过语言表达来完成。它是通过细微的手势、姿势、语调和肢体语言来完成的。但当你不得不通过电话或FaceTime与伴侣进行那些艰难的对话时，很多细节就丢失了，我们可能会误解对方的意思，或者感到缺乏信任和亲密感，觉得无法真正相信对方。当然，这里还有一个因素，那就是缺乏共同
experiences, you know, building shared experiences and creating memories with a partner is essential. It's an essential part of any relationship, not even just romantic. So in long distance relationships, I know it sounds kind of obvious, but the physical distance, limits our ability to share these experiences on a regular basis. It makes us feel disconnected. It makes us feel like we are living separate lives, which in some ways we are. And I know this perspective around why it's so hard is somewhat, somewhat negative and maybe a bit of a downer. But I think all of this is just to say that, A, if you're considering this, you should go into it prepared and B, if this is you currently, it's not your fault for feeling conflicted or for
经历。你知道，与伴侣共同构建经历和创造回忆是至关重要的。这是任何关系中必不可少的一部分，甚至不仅仅是恋爱关系。所以在异地恋中，我知道这听起来有点显而易见，但物理距离限制了我们定期分享这些经历的能力。这让我们感到彼此脱节。让我们觉得自己在过着截然不同的人生——某种程度上确实如此。我知道这种关于为什么异地这么难的观点有点消极，可能有点让人扫兴。但所有这些其实只是想说明：A，如果你正在考虑异地，你应该做好心理准备；B，如果你目前正处于这种状态，感到纠结或
finding this hard. It's biological. It's social. It's psychological. But it doesn't mean that it's the end because a lot of the time it can be worth it if the person is worth it. I was in this relationship during university. You'll know who that was with. If you listened to my episode with my ex, I actually need to do a follow up on that. But besides the point, we did long distance for four months during the COVID lockdowns. And when I tell you, it got to the point where we almost broke up every week, I'm not even joking. It was unbearable. And when I could finally go and see him when the travel restrictions eased, I remember feeling like, okay, I'm going to go and I'm going to break up with him.
觉得这很难并不是你的错。这是生物学的、社会的、心理的。但这并不意味着这就是终点，因为很多时候，如果这个人值得，这一切都是值得的。我在大学期间经历过这样的感情。如果听过我和前任的那期节目，你们就知道那是谁了。我其实需要做个后续更新。但抛开这一点不谈，我们在新冠封锁期间进行了四个月的异地恋。当我说我们甚至到了几乎每周都要分手的地步时，我真的一点都没开玩笑。那种感觉简直无法忍受。当旅行限制放松，我终于能去看他时，我记得当时感觉：好吧，我要去和他分手，
and I literally told my housemates that I would be back that evening. I did the three-hour drive to where he was living. I cried the entire time. And when I saw him, it was like everything was totally fine. We were fine. It just fell right back into place. When you do see each other, it feels like a honeymoon. It feels like a vacation.
我甚至告诉我的室友我那天晚上就会回来。我开车三个小时去了他住的地方。一路上我都在哭。但当我见到他时，就好像一切完全没事了。我们很好。一切都顺理成章地回到了原位。当你真正相聚时，感觉就像在度蜜月。感觉就像在度假。
You just connect on a whole new level. You know, it's like this huge rush of all of those happy, positive hormones. And we all know the saying, you know, distance makes the heart grow fonder. And I never realized the truth behind that until that moment. And of course, if you've been in a long distance relationship for some time and you are seeing each other more regularly than once every four months, I'm sure you'll experience a lot less of the cumulative and built-up stress. But it also makes your time together so special and so precious
你们在全新的层面上建立连接。你知道，这就好像是一股巨大的快乐、积极荷尔蒙的涌动。我们都知道那句俗语：“距离产生美”。直到那一刻，我才真正意识到背后的真相。当然，如果你已经异地恋一段时间了，而且你们见面的频率比四个月一次要高，我确信你们会经历少得多的累积压力。但这也让你们在同一个地方相聚的时间变得无比特别和珍贵，
when you are in the same location because I think you've really developed your relationship to the point where you can kind of handle anything after you've been through that period of stress and complication and distance. You know, you've built the trust, you've built the communication, the boundaries, you understand how to connect
因为我认为在经历了那段压力、复杂和距离的时期后，你们真的已经把彼此的关系发展到了几乎可以应对任何事情的程度。你知道，你们建立了信任，建立了沟通，树立了底线，你们懂得如何去连接，
and you don't really take each other for granted. I think alongside this from a psychological perspective, long-distance relationships often require us to develop independence, to develop resilience, and effective communication skills. You know, being physically separated does provide an opportunity for personal growth as you learn to kind of navigate challenges and make decisions independently. It also provides you with so much extra time to focus on your personal goals, focus on your hobbies, on your friends, self-improvement, and fostering a sense of individual fulfillment.
而且你们不会把对方的付出视为理所当然。除此之外，从心理学的角度来看，异地恋往往要求我们培养独立性、韧性和有效的沟通技巧。你知道，物理上的分离确实为个人成长提供了机会，因为你要学会独立应对挑战并做出决定。它还为你提供了大量额外的时间来专注于个人目标、发展爱好、陪伴朋友、自我完善，并培养个人的成就感。
You know, a lot of the time I see this amongst people in their 20s where we become like obsessed with our partner. Our, you know, our partner is like the core pillar and center of our universe. Sometimes it is kind of nice to break away from that and realize that you are actually two separate people. But there are some considerations and some questions. and some questions to ask yourself before you dive right in. Deciding whether to pursue a long-distance relationship, it can be a complex decision,
你知道，很多时候我在二十多岁的人身上看到这一点：我们变得像着了魔一样围着伴侣转。我们的伴侣就像是我们宇宙的核心支柱和中心。有时，能够从那种状态中抽离出来，意识到你们其实是两个独立的人，这种感觉其实挺不错的。但在你一头扎进异地恋之前，还有一些考量和问题需要问问自己。决定是否要维系一段异地恋可能是一个复杂的决定，
and psychology, of course, can provide some insights for us to consider. Here are a few that I think are particularly worthwhile to take into account. Number one, goal alignment and the future. There is no point putting yourself under this pressure if you both, see this relationship as short term. It sounds kind of like common sense, but do you actually want to be with this person in the long run? And do they feel the same? You need to discuss your long term goals and aspirations with your partner before you jump into doing long distance. Are you both on the same page regarding the future of the relationship and the willingness to eventually close
而心理学当然可以为我们提供一些可供思考的见解。以下是我认为特别值得考虑的几点。第一点：目标一致与未来。如果你们俩都将这段感情视为短期的，那么让自己承受这种压力就毫无意义。这听起来有点像常识，但从长远来看，你真的想和这个人在一起吗？他们也是这么想的吗？在开始异地恋之前，你需要和伴侣讨论你们的长期目标和抱负。你们对于这段感情的未来是否达成共识，是否愿意最终结束
that gap and close the distance? Do you have a shared vision? Do you both have the same idea around your priorities, whether you want a family, where the relationship is headed? If you're not on the same page around your values and your goals, the relationship is either going to crumble really quickly or you're going to find yourself in the same location again and then be like, what was the point of doing all of this? So I would say having a shared sense of direction and purpose will help you navigate the challenges and make you feel like it's worth it. The second thing to consider before you get into a long distance relationship is communication. I feel like once again, super common sense, but effective communication is crucial in any
这种异地状态并消除距离？你们是否有共同的愿景？你们对于彼此的优先级是否有相同的想法，比如是否想要孩子，感情将走向何方？如果你们在价值观和目标上没有达成共识，这段感情要么会迅速崩塌，要么就是你们再次聚到一起时会想：做这一切到底有什么意义？所以我认为，拥有共同的方向感和目标感将帮助你们克服挑战，让你们觉得这一切都是值得的。在开启异地恋之前需要考虑的第二件事是沟通。我觉得这又是一个超级常识，但在任何关系中，有效的沟通都至关重要，在异地情况下更是如此。反思一下你们的沟通风格。你们中是否有一方比较好斗？是否有一方会封闭自己？
relationship, but even more in this situation. Reflect on your communication styles. Is one of you a bit more hostile? Does one of you close off? what is your willingness, your equal willingness to be open and honest. And I think you have to realize that there will be effort there in investing and maintaining a strong connection, not just in terms of your communication styles, but also in terms of practical things like time zones and work schedules.
你们是否同样愿意坦诚相待。而且你必须意识到，为了投入和维持强大的连接，这里需要付出努力，不仅是在沟通风格方面，在诸如时区和工作日程等实际问题上也是如此。
And, you know, your life is no longer conveniently in parallel. It's now kind of perpendicular where you meet at one single point during the day and you have to try and create situations where that is going to be most ideal for both of you. The third thing I would say is trust. You know, trust is such a nuanced psychological idea and it is the foundation of any successful relationship. But essentially it is this idea that you know that that other person will be in your corner and will make decisions in both their best interest but also your own.
而且，你知道，你们的生活不再那么巧合地平行了。现在它有点像垂直相交，你们在一天中的某个单一时间点交汇，而你们必须努力创造对双方都最理想的情况。我要说的第三点是信任。你知道，信任是一个非常微妙的心理学概念，它是任何成功关系的基础。但本质上，这种观念意味着你知道另一个人会站在你这边，在做决定时既符合他们自身的利益，也符合你
own best interest. And I think when you do long distance, the entire context of it is that you don't get to spend quality time and have hard discussions in person. And if you are someone who is particularly jealous or perhaps has an anxious attachment style or childhood wounds surrounding abandonment, you are going to be triggered by your partner moving away. So it may be worth having a deeper discussion about how you're going to manage that, what level of reassurance you need, what level of frequency of communication you're after, because unless you're both capable of fostering and preserving trust over the distance, it might be worth just simply going on a break. The fourth element and consideration is your emotional and physical needs.
自身的利益。我认为当你异地恋时，整个背景就是你无法花优质时间进行面对面的艰难讨论。如果你是一个特别嫉妒，或者可能具有焦虑型依附风格，或有着关于被抛弃的童年创伤的人，你的伴侣搬走这件事会触发你的这些情绪。所以，花点时间深入讨论你们将如何应对这种情况、你需要多少程度的安心感、你追求多频繁的沟通，可能非常有必要，因为除非你们都有能力在距离中培养和维护信任，否则可能真的不如干脆暂停一下。第四个要素和考量是你的情感与生理需求。
Consider what your physical needs are as well as those of your partner. you are someone who likes to have sex all the time, if you are someone whose primary love language is physical touch and quality time, a long distance relationship is going to require more effort from you because your immediate romantic needs are not going to be fulfilled in the same way that they were when that person was close. So I think you really need to evaluate that trade-off. Are you willing to give up what you need physically and emotionally for in the short term or are you someone who actually needs that input and stimulation and those needs fulfilled more regularly? You know, I think that you need to be honest. Both of you
考虑一下你以及你伴侣的生理需求是什么。如果你是一个随时都想做爱的人，如果你的主要爱语是身体触碰和高质量的陪伴，那么异地恋将需要你付出更多的努力，因为你即时的恋爱需求将无法像伴侣在身边时那样得到满足。所以我认为你真的需要权衡这种得失。你是愿意在短期内在生理和情感上放弃所需，还是你其实是一个真正需要这种输入、刺激和需求得到更定期满足的人？你知道，我认为你需要诚实。你们两个
need to be honest about whether that is too much of a hurdle, you know, whether you should open up your relationship, whether you should see other people, or whether it's something that you're willing to sacrifice in the short term for the long term outcome and output of being. together. And the final consideration is your support system. Distance is really hard and it will definitely put pressure on your personal well-being no matter how healthy and stable your relationship is. It will also make you feel lonely. I think in most relationships our partner is our primary source of socialization and source of entertainment and we spend so much time with them. So evaluate the alternatives there. And do you?
都需要诚实地面对这是否是一个太大的障碍，你知道，你们是否应该开放式恋爱，是否应该去见其他人，或者这是不是你为了长远结果而愿意在短期内做出牺牲的事情。最后需要考量的是你的支持系统。距离真的很艰难，无论你的关系多么健康稳定，它绝对会给你的个人幸福感带来压力。它也会让你感到孤独。我认为在大多数关系中，我们的伴侣是我们主要的社交和娱乐来源，我们花大量时间与他们在一起。所以要评估那里的替代方案。你是否有
have a support system available to you. I think it's really helpful to have friends or family or some other source of support who can provide you with emotional and practical assistance during challenging times or when that is not available from your partner. We are not meant to be isolated solitary creatures. We are not meant to be deprived of physical touch or deprived of emotional intimacy. So even though there may be distance in your relationship, you should still be getting those needs fulfilled elsewhere. Otherwise, I think it's not really worth considering whether long distance is the right decision for you. It's just, it's just obviously not. Ultimately, I do think the decision to pursue a long distance relationship is highly individual. I can't
可用的支持系统？我认为拥有朋友、家人或其他支持来源真的很有帮助，他们可以在充满挑战的时期，或者当你的伴侣无法陪伴时，为你提供情感和实际的援助。我们注定不是孤立的孤独生物。我们不应该被剥夺身体接触或被剥夺情感亲密。所以，即使你们的感情存在距离，你依然应该在其他地方满足这些需求。否则，我认为真的不值得去考虑异地恋是否适合你。那——那显然是不合适的。归根结底，我认为追求异地恋的决定是非常个人的。我无法
give you all the answers because it is highly personal. It requires a discussion between you and your partner, introspection about your own needs, and I guess a mutual understanding of the challenges involved, but if you are both committed, you have the same goals, you are willing to put in the effort, you have worked through your attachment style, you have a strong foundation, I do think that this arrangement can succeed. And all of that in mind, I do just want to pose some major questions that I think we need to answer to determine whether this is right for you. So if you're looking for like a guidebook or like some kind of massive sign like a yes no situation, answer these questions and I think that it will really illuminate your decision for you. Firstly, in five years
给你所有的答案，因为这极其私密。它需要你和伴侣之间的讨论，对自身需求的内省，以及对所涉及挑战的共同理解。但如果你们都坚守承诺，有共同的目标，愿意付出努力，已经克服了各自的依附风格，并且拥有牢固的基础，我认为这种模式是可以成功的。考虑到所有这些，我只想提出一些我认为我们需要回答的重大问题，以确定这是否适合你。所以如果你在寻找某种指南手册或某种像“行”或“不行”这样的重大信号，回答这些问题，我认为这会真正照亮你的决定。首先，在五年
time, do you see this person in your life? Can you imagine a future together? If the answer is no, then maybe this isn't right for you. Do your long-term goals align? And if they don't, does that matter? What are your expectations? Are those shared? Are you okay with not seeing this person for more than two weeks? In your daily life, would that be upsetting for you? If your partner doesn't answer your text messages or your calls immediately, does that leave you feeling anxious? And what is your approach and strategy for jealousy. Am I prepared for hard times? What am I going to do when this happens?
后，你还能看到这个人出现在你的生活中吗？你能想象你们的未来吗？如果答案是否定的，那么这可能不适合你。你们的长期目标一致吗？如果它们不一致，这重要吗？你们的期望是什么？这些期望是共同的吗？你是否能接受超过两周见不到这个人？在日常生活中，这会让你心烦意乱吗？如果你的伴侣没有立即回复你的短信或电话，这会让你感到焦虑吗？你应对嫉妒的方法和策略是什么？我为艰难时期做好准备了吗？当这种情况发生时我要怎么做？
How will we manage conflict? I think all of these are really valuable to answer, both before and during the distance. And make sure you're brutally honest with yourself and with each other. You know, a study conducted in 2001 found that honesty is the main factor behind all of those elements of trust, of communication, of reciprocity, of closeness. So I think it's a good place to start being honest whilst you're still close to each other and then that honesty can move forward with your relationship as you face distance. You know, that involves regular
我们将如何处理冲突？我认为所有这些问题都非常值得回答，无论是在异地之前还是在异地期间。确保你对自己和对方都残酷地坦诚。你知道，2001年的一项研究发现，诚实是信任、沟通、互惠和亲密等所有元素背后的主要因素。所以我觉得这是一个好的起点，在你们彼此靠近时保持诚实，然后这种诚实可以在你们面对距离时伴随着你们的关系继续前行。你知道，这涉及到定期
check-ins and communication, which I think is vital. But there are some other strategies that we're going to discuss along with some signs that maybe it is time to call time of death on the relationship and call it quits. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the in-crack and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
的打卡和沟通，我认为这至关重要。但还有一些其他的策略，我们将同一些迹象一起讨论，这些迹象可能表明是时候宣告这段感情“死亡”并好聚好散了。所有这些以及更多内容，马上回来。2%。这是指旁边有自动扶梯时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养坚韧的精神、健康的体魄和建立心理韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的花哨且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们真的以为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。搜索单词“T-W-O-Percent”，即可在I-Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或各大播客平台收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击莉莉·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉莉·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple. podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，
and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
却依然在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way.
绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct?
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测报告两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We want our relationships to work and we want to give them the best chance we can,
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了法律后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我们希望我们的关系能够长久，我们希望给它们最好的机会，
especially when we feel like we found the right one. You know, that is really hard to do. Let me tell you. So you want to hold on to that. And I think the distance doesn't have to mean the of our relationship, especially when we go into it rationally and with shared expectations, but also some good strategies. So here are some very practical tips from my own experience, but also from friends and from some amazing therapists that I think are really useful. There's five and they are the most repeated themes for managing long distance. First of all, if this is you right now, you need to plan ahead. Set a date. date for when you are going to see each other next. And I think that psychologically, time apart
尤其是当我们觉得找到了对的人的时候。你知道，这真的很难做到。我跟你说。所以你要坚持这一点。我认为距离并不一定意味着关系的结束，尤其是当我们以理性、共同的期望以及一些好的策略来对待它时。所以这里有一些来自我自己的经验，也有来自朋友和一些优秀的治疗师的非常实用的建议，我觉得真的很有用。总共有五个，它们是维持异地恋最常提到的主题。首先，如果这就是你现在的处境，你需要提前计划。定个日期。定下你们下次见面具体的日子。我认为在心理上，分开的时间
is made easier when it has an end date that you can look forward to. It allows us to view separation and these hard times as temporary. And there's even been research into this that suggested that perceiving negative events like doing long distance as time limited can actually lead to better psychological well-being and coping. You know, our perception of time is influenced by the anticipation of an end date. When we set a time frame, it can create a psychological time horizon effect and it makes it appear like the time apart is moving faster. We feel more mentally prepared and feels like things are moving quicker and provides more of a sense of control. So all of those amazing things, I think every time you see your partner,
如果有一个你可以期待的结束日期，就会变得更容易一些。它让我们能够把分离和这些艰难时期视为暂时的。甚至还有关于这方面的研究表明，将异地恋等消极事件视为有时间限制的，实际上可以带来更好的心理健康和应对能力。你知道，我们对时间的感知会受到对结束日期的期待的影响。当我们设定一个时间框架时，它可以产生心理上的时间地平线效应，并使分开的时间看起来过得更快。我们在精神上感觉准备得更充分，觉得事情进展得更快，并提供了更多的掌控感。所以所有这些奇妙的事情，我认为每次你见你的伴侣，
Make sure that you have an end goal in sight and plan for the next time you'll see each other psychologically. It will literally help you manage that so much better. I think the second tip is around setting up date nights, developing enjoyable rituals and maintaining emotional intimacy. Often when we enter into a long-distance dynamic, the first thing we sacrifice is of course quality time. And with that, emotional intimacy. think those things are very easy to cultivate when you are close and when you are conveniently close to a partner. But when there's distance, obviously that's less easy. So set aside dedicated time for virtual date nights and plan out activities that you can both enjoy together and kind
确保你有一个明确的最终目标，并在心理上规划你们下一次见面。这真的会极大地帮助你更好地应对异地恋。我认为第二个建议是关于建立约会之夜、培养愉快的仪式感以及维持情感亲密。通常当我们进入异地恋的状态时，我们首先牺牲的当然是高质量的陪伴。随之而来的，就是情感上的亲密。我认为这些事情在你们亲近且地理位置便利的时候很容易培养。但是当有了距离，显然这就没有那么容易了。所以，留出专门的时间来进行虚拟约会之夜，并规划你们都可以一起享受的活动，并保持
of maintain excitement and novelty in the relationship. You know, novelty is important. You want to feel like you're still dating. When I was doing long distance, we used to do these things called dinner dates where we would both cook the same recipe together over Zoom, we would buy the same bottle of wine and we would eat together over like literal video. We would like sit down and have dinner with each other through our laptops. Obviously not as good as the real thing, but I guess it leads into my next strategy, which is to put effort into those shared experiences. You don't need to give up on joint interests and creating shared memories or sharing in activities together just because you're miles away.
保持关系中的新鲜感和兴奋感。你知道，新鲜感很重要。你会希望觉得你们还在约会。当我经历异地恋时，我们过去常常做一些叫做“晚餐约会”的事情，我们会通过Zoom一起烹饪相同的食谱，我们会买同一瓶酒，然后通过真实的视频一起吃饭。我们就像是通过笔记本电脑坐在一起共进晚餐。当然不如真实的见面好，但这我想正好引申到我的下一个策略，那就是在这些共同体验上投入精力。你不需要因为你们相隔数英里就放弃共同的兴趣、创造共同的回忆或一起参与活动。
I think after COVID, the world has evolved to be a lot more digital and virtual. And that's to the benefit of people who are doing a long distance. You know, there are so many things you can do together like words with friends or you can play Scrabble or you can do, I don't know, video games. Do I sound like an idiot saying that? Video games, you can do those together online, right? I think so. Correct me if I'm wrong.
我认为在新冠疫情之后，世界已经变得更加数字化和虚拟化。这对异地恋的人来说是个福音。你知道，你们有很多事情可以一起做，比如 Words with Friends，或者你可以玩拼字游戏（Scrabble），或者你可以，我不知道，玩电子游戏。我说这话听起来像个白痴吗？电子游戏，你们可以在网上一起玩，对吧？我想是的。如果我错了请纠正我。
But just things like that. watching movies using a shared screening service. It feels like you're both in there together. It feels like you're both doing something, a ritual, an activity that provides a sense of stability. It provides a sense of comfort and shared identity in the relationship. I've already mentioned this, but of course, check-ins, regular check-ins, once a month, set up some time to ask yourself and ask your partner, difficult questions. What could each of you be doing better?
但就是类似这样的事情。通过共享放映服务一起看电影。这感觉就像你们俩都在那里。这感觉就像你们俩都在做一件事，一种仪式，一项能够提供稳定感的活动。它在两性关系中提供了一种舒适感和共同的身份认同。我已经提到过了，当然还有定期检查，定期检查，一个月一次，留出一些时间来问问自己和你的伴侣一些难题。你们每个人都可以做得更好的是什么？
there's something that you're missing, what's been happening in your lives that maybe you haven't spoken about. I think it all comes back to that core factor for success, which is open communication and trust. Those are your crucial ingredients here. And finally, my fifth tip is kind of silly, but it's actually really useful. That is to create a vision board or some physical reminder of why you're doing this. Long distance is a marathon. It's not a sprint. And it's kind of like this joint long-term goal you're pursuing together with the aim of one day being reunited.
如果有什么是你所怀念的，你们的生活中发生了什么可能还没有谈论过的事情。我认为这一切都归结于成功的核心要素，那就是公开的沟通和信任。这些是你们这里的关键成分。最后，我的第五个建议有点傻，但其实非常有用。那就是建立一个愿景板或一些身体上的提醒，提醒你为什么要这样做。异地恋是一场马拉松。它不是短跑。这有点像你们为了有朝一日能够团聚的目标，而共同追求的长期目标。
When we treat it like a mutual goal, this greatly helps our perception of how achievable this will be. And we can use visual cues to help us with this. When you're not seeing each other every day, you can forget why you're doing it. create some vision board or physical reminder of what the long-term future holds. Maybe that's like a dream life collaborative Pinterest board or a picture of where you're going to go on vacation next or a piece of their clothing or a visual, tangible item that reminds you of them to keep them close and centered on why you're doing this in the first place. That's just a selection.
当我们把它当作一个共同的目标时，这会极大地帮助我们感知这有多么容易实现。我们可以用视觉线索来帮助我们做到这一点。当你们不常见面时，你可能会忘记你为什么要这么做。创建一个愿景板或实体提醒，提醒你长期未来蕴含着什么。也许那是一个梦想生活的合作 Pinterest 板，或者是一张你们接下来要去度假的地方的照片，或者是一件他们的衣服，或者是一个视觉上的、有形的东西，提醒你他们，让你把他们放在首选和中心，提醒你你为什么要这样做。这只是一种选择。
Obviously, there are other notable tips, including expressing affection regularly, practicing gratitude, whatever keeps you connected. However, we're talking about a dilemma here. Sometimes you can be doing all of these things and it's still not enough. A big question I get is, when do we know it's time to end things? When is the distance just too much? When is it no longer worth it? that's a huge question. You know, I think sometimes it's not always that immediate decision of do I break up with them now or do I try a long distance? What happens when you've given it a go and it's just not working? I think it's a really hard thing to say. But once you're even having these thoughts or even contemplating ending things, that is the biggest indicator that it may be time to have some serious conversations because there is obviously some deepest
显然，还有其他值得注意的建议，包括定期表达爱意、实践感恩之情、任何能让你们保持联系的事情。然而，我们在这里讨论的是一个困境。有时你可能做了所有这些事情，但仍然不够。我经常遇到的一个问题是，我们什么时候才知道是时候结束这一切了？什么时候距离真的太远了？什么时候它变得不值得了？这是一个巨大的问题。你知道，我觉得有时候这并不总是那种立即做出决定的是现在就和他分手还是尝试异地恋？当你试过了却发现根本行不通时会发生什么？我觉得这是一件很难说出口的事情。但一旦你甚至有了这些想法，甚至在考虑结束这段关系，这往往是最重要的信号，表明可能是时候进行一些严肃的对话了，因为其中显然存在一些更深层次的
dissatisfaction there that you're beginning to recognize that's beginning to bubble up and coming to that realization can be so difficult and I think we often hold off on doing that and doing what we know is right because of a lot of factors the first one being this idea of the sunk cost fallacy this is this idea that we feel compelled to continue investing in a relationship even when it no longer serves us simply because you have already invested significant time, effort, or emotions. So often what happens is we believe and we come to believe this fallacy, this false narrative, that ending the relationship would mean wasting those past investments. It would mean that you wasted your time. And we never want to see something as a waste as humans. So we stay,
那里的不满意是你开始注意到的，开始涌现出来的，而意识到这一点是如此困难，我认为我们往往会推迟这样做，推迟做我们明知正确的事，原因有很多，第一个就是所谓的沉没成本谬论。这是一种这样的想法：即使一段关系不再适合我们，我们也觉得被迫继续投入，仅仅是因为你已经投入了大量的时间、精力或情感。所以经常发生的情况是，我们相信并开始相信这个谬论，这个虚假的叙事，即结束这段关系将意味着浪费那些过去的投资。这意味着你浪费了你的时间。作为人类，我们永远不想把任何事情视为浪费。所以我们留下来，
despite the fact that we are unhappy. Every single, situation is unique and I will continue to repeat that because it's not a one size fits all approach but when the emotional connection between you and your partner has significantly diminished, when you can no longer communicate, when you are not excited to hear from them, when they do not regularly reach out, when you dread the future, when you are frustrated or you have doubts, when you can no longer picture them in your future or you're experiencing resists, resentment, your relationship is no longer fulfilling you. What is the point of being in a relationship at this point? Obviously, everything is going to come with hard moments, but I think life is really
尽管我们很不开心。每一种情况都是独一无二的，我会继续重复这一点，因为它不是一种一刀切的方法，但当你和伴侣之间的情感联系显著减弱时，当你无法再沟通时，当你不再为听到他们的消息而兴奋时，当他们不再经常联系你时，当你对未来感到恐惧时，当你感到沮丧或怀疑时，当你再也无法在未来想象他们的身影，或者你正在经历抵抗、怨恨，你的关系不再满足你。在这种情况下谈恋爱还有什么意义？显然，任何事情都会有艰难的时刻，但我认为人生真的很
short and our 20s are even shorter. Your relationships are meant to build on already a strong foundation and make you feel better. So do you really want to spend this decade and this time unhappy or feeling anxious or unsupported. Maybe this is the time for you to be alone. I'm also a firm believer that you can love someone twice and you can come back to each other if the time and the circumstances are right, it doesn't have to be goodbye forever. But if you are persistently, consistently, unhappy, and you feel like there is not enough investment or effort from each of you mutually to push through. This may not be what's right for you at this moment in time. So what do we do next? You know, no one likes to be broken up with over the phone. So how do you navigate bringing
短暂，我们的20多岁更是转瞬即逝。你的恋爱关系应该建立在已经坚实的基础之上，并且让你感觉更好。所以你真的想在这个十年里一直不快乐、感到焦虑或得不到支持吗？也许现在是你独处的时候了。我也坚信，你可以爱一个人两次，如果时机和环境合适，你们可以回到彼此身边，这不一定是永远的告别。但如果你一直以来、持续不断地感到不快乐，并且觉得你们双方都没有足够的投入或努力来度过难关。此时此刻，这可能并不适合你。那我们接下来该怎么做？你知道，没有人喜欢通过电话被分手，所以当你们可能不在同一个城市、同一个州甚至同一个国家时，你该如何应对这件事？
this up when you're maybe not in the same city or the same state or even the same country? It's a sensitive conversation to be having. But I think flag your thoughts and feelings in advance before you plan to see each other next so that no one is blindsided. It may, I think, also provide you with an opportunity and the time to work on things in the meantime, you know, and if that isn't fruitful and the challenges are still there, make sure you prepare them for the fact that you want to have a difficult conversation. And I would say, if possible, do it in person. I know that's really difficult or over video, something that feels more personal to honor your relationship and to respect the other person. I guess what I'm trying to say is that it shouldn't
这是一个敏感的对话。但我认为，在你计划下次见面之前，提前表达你的想法和感受，这样就不会让人措手不及。我认为，这也可能为你提供一个机会和时间，在此期间努力改善事情，你知道，如果这没有成效，挑战依然存在，确保让他们做好心理准备，让他们知道你想进行一次艰难的对话。我想说，如果可能的话，当面说。我知道这真的很难，或者通过视频，感觉更个人化的一些事情来尊重你们的关系并尊重对方。我想我要说的是，这不应该
come as a surprise. Be honest, be clear, allow for emotional expression from both of you and of course set those breakup boundaries. And sometimes after we've ripped the Band-Aid off, we realize that we've kind of been checked out for some time. And I think, think that although all breakups are hard, you've kind of already gone through the process of creating distance. And sometimes it's easy to heal when you know that you're not going to have to run into them on the street or at your local cafe, you know, a small consolation here, small consolation prize, but the distance may actually work in your favor here. If you would like to see it that way, if you'd like to make that part of your perspective.
出人意料。诚实、明确，允许你们两个人都表达情感，当然还要设定分手的界限。有时，在我们撕掉创可贴后，我们意识到我们其实已经抽离一段时间了。我认为，尽管所有分手都很艰难，但你其实已经经历了一个产生距离的过程。有时，当你明知自己不会在大街上或当地的咖啡馆偶遇他们时，疗伤会变得容易一些，你知道，这算是一个小小的安慰，一个小小的安慰奖，但距离实际上可能会对你有利。如果你愿意这样看待它，如果你愿意把它作为你视角的一部分。
Every relationship is so nuanced and unique. So I would take this advice with grain of salt and reflect on what's right for you. I'm not someone who tells everyone to go out there and break up with their partners just because they're slightly unhappy. I think that it's about really examining whether the relationship is actually evolving with you or whether you are changing for the relationship and changing for another person or feeling like you have to give up on your dreams to maintain something that's never the way that we want to be behaving in our 20s or at any stage in our lives, but we also can't deny that distance is going to be hard, have some self-compassion. We obviously want to be close to the ones that we love for many psychological and physical reasons.
每一段感情都是如此微妙和独特。所以我建议大家对这些建议持保留态度，并反思什么对你来说才是正确的。我不是那种仅仅因为别人有点不开心就叫他们出去跟伴侣分手的人。我认为关键在于真正审视这段关系是否真的在与你共同进化，或者你是否为了这段关系而改变，为了另一个人而改变，或者觉得为了维系某些东西而不得不放弃自己的梦想——这绝不是我们在20多岁或生命任何阶段应有的表现，但我们也无法否认距离会很艰难，要对自己多一点同情心。出于许多心理和生理原因，我们显然希望离我们爱的人近一点。
So you're going to struggle regardless, but it doesn't mean a death sentence for your relationship. When there is an angle in sight, when you have those clear timelines, when you treat it like a shared goal, I really think that it can be worth. it and you can work on it if your bond is worth it if this person really is the one no relationship is ever going to be easy i'm just going to say that one final time i know i sound like a broken record but it can be distance it can be you know you can still feel distanced when someone is sitting right next to you and you can still be full of jealousy when you guys live together you can still feel like you're not communicating when you are around each other all the time right it's just about realizing that
所以你无论如何都会挣扎，但这并不意味着你的关系被判了死刑。当有一个明确的目标在眼前，当你有这些清晰的时间表，当你把它当作一个共同的目标时，我真的认为这是值得的。如果你们的羁绊值得，如果这个人真的是那个对的人，你可以去努力经营。没有任何一段关系会是一帆风顺的，我最后一次这么说。我知道我听起来像个碎碎念的老唱片，但可能会有距离的问题，你知道，当有人坐在你旁边时，你仍然会感到疏离；你们住在一起，你仍然会充满嫉妒；你们整天都在一起，你仍然会觉得自己无法沟通，对吧？这只是关于意识到
that is possibly going to be exacerbated and having the strategies and the forward thinking to plan for that. What a jam-packed episode. I feel like long distance is such a dilemma. So if you are in a long-distance relationship right now or you're contemplating it, you're contemplating the freedoms that you might have to give up, the choices you might have to make, I hope this has helped you out. You know, I've been there, done that, got the T-shirt. It wasn't fun, but there's really something to be said with being able to see your partner after six months apart, it does make the heart grow fonder. They will say that. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode, that you learned something, that it provided you with practical guidance or just something to think about. As always,
这可能会被加剧，并需要采取策略和前瞻性思维来为此做计划。多么内容丰富的一集节目啊。我觉得异地恋真是一个巨大的困境。所以如果你现在正处于异地恋中，或者你在考虑异地恋，你在考虑你可能不得不放弃的自由，你可能不得不做出的选择，我希望这能对你有所帮助。你知道，我经历过，也做过，深有体会。这并不有趣，但能够看到你的伴侣在分开六个月后再次相聚，确实能让感情更加深厚。他们都是这么说的。所以我真的很希望你喜欢这一集，你学到了一些东西，它为你提供了实用的指导，或者只是给你带来了一些思考。一如既往，
if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really helps the show to grow and meet new people. maybe there is someone in your life who needs to hear this. You should send it to them. I'm sure they would appreciate it. And I will say this topic wouldn't have been done. I wouldn't have thought to do it without suggestions from people over on Instagram. I'm always looking for new topics to cover new ideas, new things that are being experienced by our generation.
如果你真的喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和结识新朋友很有帮助。也许你生命中有谁需要听到这个。你应该把它发给她。我确信他们会感激的。我要说的是，如果没有来自 Instagram 上网友们的建议，我根本不会想到做这个话题。我一直在寻找新的话题来涵盖新的想法，寻找我们这一代人正在经历的新事物。
So follow me over there at that psychology podcast if you have an idea or something that you would like me. to explore further. As always, thanks for tagging along. Thanks for joining in. I will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happy, your more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
所以在那里关注我吧，那个心理学播客，如果你有任何想法或者有什么你想让我进一步探索的事情。一如既往，感谢一路同行。感谢收听。我下周会带着另一集回归。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down,
就在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO%。在《Look Back at It》播客中。对于1979年来说，对我而言那是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是怎么挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back At It。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的经历。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼（Michael Ranjini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证是由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。